we've been told people had fled for
safety to this police station
we found them exhausted and scared
terrorized out of their homes by mobs
two days ago hitting my son like this
eating
your pakistani sleeping myself in front
of me
15 more than 50 people came my house
when we came outside
the people are waiting for us with the
sticks and with the knives over there
they're migrants from pakistan and
afghanistan singled out by local sri
lankans
blaming them for the easter sunday
attacks after the bombers the people are
against us
they're attacking on our houses and
they're just hating our kids and
everything they're just telling us okay
you can't stay here run away what will
happen to you if you leave the police
station do you think
they will definitely be there they have
no idea when they will feel safe enough
to leave here
they're the overlooked victims of the
bomb attacks
traumatized and some completely
overwhelmed by their ordeal
camping out in the police station garage
wherever they can find space
who wants that is possible for us in our
country we are also not safe in pakistan
and [ __ ] so we are not safe the
responsibility
said not to come for media we've been
told we can't film her anymore but this
is a desperate situation these are
refugees so they've already been
chased out of their own home countries
they've now been hounded out of their
homes here
by mobs and they are being forced to
take sanctuary in a police station
it gives a very clear sense of the
potential unrest the tensions here
uh that are very present in the wake of
the bombings on easter sunday
the catholic church in this town saw the
greatest loss of life in sunday's
attacks
and feelings are running high can we
come in and film
we need to come in with our camera in
the town's mosque we were told another
250 people have also sought sanctuary
under heavy police protection more
families forced out of their homes
afraid for their lives
in the town stores owned by muslims are
shuttered
some of them boarded with windows
smashed by stones
this is what the terrorists had in mind
attacks designed to exploit division
in a country no stranger to sectarian
unrest
the air is thickening with tension here
it might ease and pass over
or erupt into something much worse
dominic waghorn sky news negombo